Hallo zusammen!
Wir machen heute extrem softe Vanilleschnecken.
Die sind extrem extrem extrem weich, die müsst ihr unbedingt mal ausprobieren!
Ich persönlich kann mich nie beherrschen und muss direkt mehrere essen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt direkt mal hier meinen Hefeteig.
Der ist sehr sehr pflegeleicht, den liebe ich.
Den könnt ihr entweder mit den sauberen Händen verkneten oder ihr nehmt einfach die Küchenmaschine, so mache ich es heute.
Ich hab jetzt hier zuallererst lauwarme Milch.
Die sollte nicht wärmer als ungefähr 38°C sein, also wirklich nur ganz leicht z.B. in der Mikrowelle erwärmen.
Ist immer gut für die Hefe, die gebe ich jetzt direkt hier rein.
Dazu kommt frische Hefe.
Ihr dürft auch gerne Trockenhefe benutzen, das schreibe ich euch genau wie alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben aber unten in die Infobox.
Das gebe ich noch mit dazu.
Und dann kommen noch Zucker und Vanilleextrakt hinzu und das Ganze wird dann einmal kurz verrührt.
Jetzt kommt geschmolzene Butter dazu - die habe ich vorab in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen - und die Eier.
Bei den Eiern ist es so, dass ich mir ein Eigelb beiseite lege weil ich das gleich zum Bestreichen brauche
und das Eiweiß braucht ihr nicht wegschmeißen, das kommt einfach in den Teig.
Als nächstes fehlt ja nur noch Mehl und da mache ich es so:
Es kommt natürlich auch auf die Größe der Eier an, wie viel Mehl ihr letztendlich braucht. Mal brauche ich 480g, mal 500g.
Ich mache es so: Ich gebe jetzt erstmal ca. 400g da rein
und die letzten 100g gebe ich dann immer - Schluck für Schluck hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt! -
so portionsweise, stückchenweise rein und lasse das Ganze dann schon mal ganz langsam verkneten, das dauert so 3-4min.
Wenn ihr mögt, könnt ihr später mit den Händen weiterkneten um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen
aber alles in allem ist das ein wirklich sehr sehr einfach herzustellender Hefeteig.
So, der Teig sieht gut aus!
Der ist sehr, sehr, sehr geschmeidig und der darf nicht mehr an den Händen kleben.
Ihr dürft aber auch nicht zu viel Mehl dazugeben, wirklich nur so...
Ich muss euch das mal von Nahem zeigen damit's bei euch auch perfekt gelingt.
Wenn ihr den so anfasst, dann dürft ihr an den Händen nichts mehr kleben haben.
So... jetzt rolle ich den - oder ich forme den zu einer Kugel besser gesagt
decke den ab und lasse ihn dann 1h gehen.
Falls ihr noch ein bisschen Öl oder Backtrennspray habt, dann macht das gerne noch mit da rein
und auf die Oberfläche, dann kann das nämlich auch nicht austrocknen.
Während unser Hefeteig jetzt geht -
Übrigens ein kleiner Tipp: Gerade jetzt hier in der offenen Küche, ich hab's nämlich am Anfang als wir hier eingezogen sind gemerkt.
Ein Hefeteig hat es wirklich gerne warm und kuschelig aber auch nicht zu heiß!
Also so 30°C oder einfach auf Zimmertemperatur oder im geschlossenen Backofen, das ist auch in Ordnung.
Aber Hefeteig mag keinen Durchzug, sonst fällt er nämlich in sich zusammen.
Gerade bei Personen mit einer offenen Küche z.B. oder wenn das Fenster offen steht.
Einfach ein Quick Tipp am Rande! Jetzt machen wir in der Zwischenzeit schon mal den leckeren Vanillepudding.
Der ist auch super easy.
Ich nehme hier diesen..ähm.. also Vanillepuddingpulver fertig aus der Tüte,
füge da aber noch extra Vanilleextrakt dazu und verrühre das jetzt zuallererst mal mit Milch und Zucker
und dann lassen wir das unter ständigem Rühren aufkochen.
Und falls ihr's nicht gemerkt habt: Dieses Video ist in Zusammenarbeit mit dem sympathischsten Supermarkt in ganz Deutschland entstanden, nämlich mit Kaufland!
[Hamza] Jetzt fehlt noch ein Daumen nach oben!
Sobald euer Pudding aufkocht dickt er auch schon ein.
Ihr könnt ihn dann direkt vom Herd nehmen, in eine Schüssel geben
und direkt an der Oberfläche mit Frischhaltefolie abdecken damit er keine Haut zieht.
Auch das lassen wir kurz abkühlen.
Jetzt ist in der Zwischenzeit auch die Ruhzeit von meinem Hefeteig vergangen und der ist richtig, richtig schön aufgegangen!
Perfekt! Man sieht die Vanillestückchen sogar im Teig, das sieht so gut aus!
Ich werde jetzt die Arbeitsfläche ganz, ganz leicht bemehlen.
Eigentlich muss man das schon fast gar nicht aber sicher ist sicher.
Und dann rollen wir ihn rechteckig aus.
Ich bin voll stolz drauf, sieht so hübsch aus! *kichtert*
[Kiki] Hamza soll ich einmal?
[Hamza] Richtige Bowlingkugel!
[Kiki] Soll ich?
[Hamza] Mach mal!
*beide lachen*
So, den Vanillepudding ganz kurz für 10sek mit 'nem Schneebesen durchrühren
und dann auf dem Hefeteig verteilen.
Den Pudding habe ich jetzt verteilt und ihr dürft gerne vorne 1 ½ - 2cm Platz lassen
denn beim Aufrollen drückt ihr den Pudding jetzt automatisch nach vorne.
Und jetzt rollt ihr von unten nach oben ganz vorsichtig und langsam auf.
Ich schreibe euch in die Infobox noch die Maße hier von meinem Hefeteig, das sind ca. 34 x 36cm.
Ich habe die Schnecken so ca. 2 ½cm dick abgeschnitten.
Macht das schön langsam, Hauptsache sie gehen euch nicht kaputt.
Ich muss sagen: Ich habe mir jetzt diese Hebepalette zur Hilfe genommen weil die sind schon extrem weich, selbst beim Durchschneiden.
Aber vertraut mir, das ist genau richtig so!
Ich habe jetzt 3 Bleche rausbekommen und die immer mit Abstand draufgelegt. Also pro Blech 5 Schnecken.
Und ja - dann werden sie im Ofen nämlich noch ein bisschen aufgehen.
Jetzt haben wir uns ja anfangs noch das Eigelb zur Seite gelegt.
Da habe ich jetzt noch einen Schluck Milch reingegeben - das ist optional, da könntet ihr jetzt auch Wasser nehmen z.B. -
und verquirle das.
Und jetzt bestreiche ich die noch vor allem auch an den Seiten, ein bisschen an der Oberfläche, damit sie auch nach dem Backen richtig hübsch aussehen.
Jetzt werden die Puddingschnecken gebacken im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze für maximal 24min.
Und so sehen sie jetzt bei mir aus!
Sie sind schon runtergekühlt und ich würd' dazu jetzt einfach noch ein Cream Cheese Frosting machen mit Vanille
weil wir ja nicht schon genug Vanille haben! Aber wenn dann soll dieses Rezept richtig Vanille-Overload sein!
Ja, auf jeden Fall nehme ich dafür ganz einfach Doppelrahmfrischkäse, ein bisschen Puderzucker für die Süße,
Vanilleextrakt und Milch, verrühre das und dann sind wir fertig!
[Kiki] Du hast das Wort!
[Hamza] Ach ich habe das Wort?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Probieren wir mal diese leckeren Schneggen!
[Kiki] Schneggen!
[Hamza] Schnegge! Ich will eine schöne Schnegge haben!
[Kiki] Ich hab die schönen hier drauf! Also ganz kurz:
[Kiki] Ihr habt jetzt in der letzten Szene gesehen, wie ich das Frosting gemacht habe -
[Hamza] Hast du noch eine wärmere?
[Hamza] Ah, der ist warm, der ist warm!
[Kiki] Hauptsache alles mal antatschen!
[Kiki] Ganz kurz zu dem Cream Cheese Frosting:
[Kiki] Jetzt habt ihr euch bestimmt gedacht ich mach das so drüber - falsch gedacht!
[Kiki] Hamza, du darfst! Einfach reindippen!
[Hamza] Ich wollt's aber gern ohne probieren!
[Kiki] Ja okay, alles klar!
[Hamza] Dann können wir ja den Geschmackstest machen!
[Kiki] Einmal ohne und dann mit, okay!
[Kiki] Ich hab grad schon eine gegessen, ich hab's nicht ausgehalten!
[Hamza] Mmmh!
[Kiki] Richtig weich, ne?
[Hamza] Kindheit!
[Kiki] Echt?
[Kiki] Jah!
[Hamza] Was heißt Kindheit? Vor ein paar Jahren noch als ich mit der Bahn gefahren bin.
[Kiki] Immer beim Bäcker geholt!
[Hamza] Da war ich öfters mal beim Bäcker und ich liebe ja so alles mit Pudding!
[Hamza] Und das schmeckt echt richtig geil!
[Hamza] Also lange nicht mehr solche Puddingplunder-Teilchen gegessen!
[Kiki] Puddingschnecken!
[Hamza] Ja das letzte Mal war halt immer wenn ich unterwegs war und das ist so - boah, das ist einfach...
[Kiki] Zeig doch mal von innen. Man sieht das auch an diesen Bläschen!
[Kiki] Das sieht - kannst du das mal nah ranhalten?
[Hamza] Das ist richtig fluffig!
[Kiki] Ooh!
[Hamza] Richtig geil! Meinst du diese Punkte hier drin?
[Kiki] Diese Poren!
[Hamza] Soll ich mal da reingehen?
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Kiki] Ihr könnt das so ähnlich..
[Hamza] Boah, das ist heftig Kiki!
[Kiki] ..so ähnlich wie bei meinem Zimtbrot, Cinnamon Bread einfach reindippen!
[Hamza] Ist das nicht das Cinnamon Bread von diesem Pizzaladen da?
[Kiki] Auch gut, ne? Ist auch lecker, ne?
[Hamza] Boah!
[Kiki] Mit und ohne beides lecker, ich find das ist nochmal so i-Tüpfelchen!
[Hamza] Man kann theoretisch auch die Füllung weglassen und nur das essen, also mit dem Brot.
[Kiki] Ja weil der Teig, das ist mein neuer Lieblingshefeteig. Der ist durch Zufall entstanden.
[Kiki] So die Maßangaben - also Hefeteig ist fast immer gleich. Aber da habe ich mir gedacht ich pack nochmal ein Eiweiß mit in den Teig
[Kiki] Ich glaube, dass das nochmal den feinen Unterschied gemacht hat!
[Kiki] Mit der flüssigen Butter statt Öl - richtig, richtig gut!
[Kiki] Also wie gesagt: Ich schreibe euch alles ganz genau unten in die Videobeschreibung. Macht das unbedingt nach und hinterlasst diesem Video -
[Hamza] Leute, ich bin gerade... ich bin im Himmel!
[Kiki] Hamza ist schon...
[Kiki] Also hinterlasst ein Däumchen nach oben und ein kostenloses Abo wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan habt
[Kiki] und dann schreibt uns rein was wir als nächstes "Wie vom Bäcker" nachmachen sollen!
[Hamza] DIe kannst du jeden Tag jetzt machen
[Kiki] Ja! Also bis zum nächsten Video! Tschüss!
[Kiki] Eure Kiki und der Hamza!
[Hamza] Sorry, ich kann nicht reden. Ich bin einfach voll!
[Hamza] Peace and out!
[Kiki] Das ist echt richtig lecker, ne?
[Kiki] Das ist eins der besten -
[Hamza] Guck mal diese kleinen Pünktchen, diese kleinen Vanillepünktchen!
[Kiki] Ui, ui, ui! Kleine süße Pünktchen!
[Hamza] Ihr kleinen süßen!
[Kiki] Oh!